je vais commencer par saluer notre
invité du jour le docteur Jean-David
Zeitoun qui est médecin
gastro-entérologue et épidémiologiste et
auteur de deux essais remarqué sur
l'évolution de la santé humaine un
plaisir cher docteur qui tient davantage
à la qualité de votre diagnostic qu'à
l'optimiste de votre diagnostic puisque
votre dernière ouvrage s'intitule tout
simplement le suicide de l'espèce ou
comment l'humanité après avoir connu au
cours des deux dernières siècles une
formidable amélioration de son état de
santé général cette grande extension
permise par le progrès médical à
laquelle vous aviez consacré votre
ouvrage précédent et maintenant en train
de ruiner ses efforts et de se détruire
à petit feu à force de manger des
aliments
ultra transformés de respirer un air
pollué d'habiter un environnement
contaminé de consommer de l'alcool du
tabac et des réseaux sociaux la liste
est longue et chaque problème est
différent avec ses propres causes et ses
propres solutions c'est vrai mais on
reste là est aussi un piège car tout
cela forme un ensemble un système et
même un marché au sens de la théorie
économique où se rencontrent l'offre et
la demande de risque sanitaire les
risques que produisent les activités
économiques et ce qu'achètent ou
acceptent les populations avec à la clé
une épidémie de maladie chronique et une
menace pour l'humanité dans son ensemble
mais alors devant cet état de fait que
faire si votre approche
pluridisciplinaire permet de prendre de
la hauteur et de distinguer les grands
mécanismes à l'oeuvre que nous dit-elle
des solutions en termes de politiques
publiques sinon qu'elles doivent être
aussi globales et sans doute bien plus
forte qu'elle ne le sont aujourd'hui
c'est là je crois chers collègues qu'on
peut ressentir un certain vertige
puisqu'à vous lire on comprend que ce
n'est pas seulement l'économie qui nuit
à la santé c'est aussi quelque part la
démocratie du moins telle qu'elle est
organisée aujourd'hui d'où ma question
et c'est
la première que je vous pose je laisse
ensuite bien sûr l'échange en vous
donnant la parole et puis en laissant
l'ensemble des collègues vous
interpellez vous interrogez à nouveau
faudra-t-il un jour choisir entre
économie démocratie et santé voilà je
vous laisse sans plus attendre la parole
en vous remerciant encore de votre venue
ce matin ici même au Sénat devant la
délégation la prospective
bon bonjour Merci beaucoup pour
l'invitation et merci beaucoup pour la
présentation
alors est-ce qu'il faudra choisir entre
démocratie économie et santé c'était ça
votre question alors
la santé est meilleure dans les États
démocratiques par rapport aux États
autocratiques ça c'est quelque chose qui
a été étudié qui a été montré il y a des
raisons dans la théorie démocratique qui
suggère que la santé devrait être
meilleur comme le fait que les leaders
politiques peuvent être interpellés par
les populations ou qu'ils ont intérêt à
ce que la santé soit bonne c'est-à-dire
à répondre à l'intérêt général par
rapport aux intérêts particuliers et il
s'avère que ça a été montré dans une
étude qui a été publiée à quelques
années dans le landset dans les
démocraties et la santé est meilleure y
compris pas seulement avec une
dichotomie démocratie autocratie mais
avec un score beaucoup plus détaillé de
stocks démocratique ce qu'ils appelaient
dans l'article qui montrait que à chaque
fois qu'on gagne un peu de démocratie on
gagne un petit peu de santé donc la
démocratie est bonne pour la santé ça
c'est une bonne nouvelle et ça a été
plutôt bien montré
ensuite pour ce qui est de l'économie
c'est compliqué
si on regarde depuis alors la santé est
toujours bonne pour l'économie ça dans
ce sens là ça marche bien une population
en bonne santé c'est une population qui
est performante économiquement vous vous
dites qu'elle est productive et donc ça
c'est un truc qui marche bien est-ce que
l'économie est bonne pour la santé la
réponse est ça dépend donc ça dépend de
la période et ça dépend du timing à
court terme il arrive il est souvent
arrivé dans l'histoire que
l'économie soit un que que la croissance
économique qui souvent a signifié la
croissance industrielle a été mauvaise à
court terme pour la santé donc par
exemple pendant la révolution
industrielle on sait que la santé s'est
dégradé à court terme alors court terme
à l'échelle de l'histoire c'est quand
même quelques décennies mais on sait que
les beaucoup de pays qui ont fait la
révolution industrielle notamment le
premier qui était l'Angleterre a observé
une dégradation de la santé dans les
décennies qui ont suivi le début de la
première révolution industrielle avec
une augmentation de la tu as été une
augmentation de la mortalité infantile
c'est lié au fait que ça a été couplé à
l'urbanisation avec une concentration de
population dans des conditions pauvres
et sales et donc
dans le sens économie versanté à court
terme ça a déjà été négatif à long terme
historiquement la croissance économique
a été bonne pour la santé puisqu'elle a
permis d'améliorer les standards de vie
et donc la propreté la non pauvreté et
ainsi de suite et donc à long terme la
relation a souvent été bonne
aujourd'hui c'est très difficile de
répondre et je pense que personne n'a la
réponse mais
qui explique le livre c'est que beaucoup
des risques produits par la société
mondiale sont des risques qui
appartiennent à la croissance économique
et donc il est possible que aujourd'hui
on est une croissance économique qui
dans l'ensemble soit devenu trop
mauvaise pour la santé elle a toujours
été à la fois bonne et mauvaise et la
réponse était dans l'équilibre entre le
bon et le mauvais mais aujourd'hui il
est possible qu'elle soit devenue trop
mauvaise alors peut-être pas plus
mauvaise que bonne mais trop mauvaise
quand même et donc je vais donner les
principales les principaux impacts qui
sont exposés dans le chapitre
d'exposition du livre donc la pollution
qui est liée à la croissance économique
ce n'est pas inévitable mais aujourd'hui
c'est lié à la croissance économique
c'est 9 millions de morts par an dont
50000 en France en sachant que dans le
monde il y a à peu près 58 millions de
morts par an le tabac qui est un secteur
économique c'est entre 7 et 8 millions
de morts par an l'obésité qui est liée à
une partie de l'industrie alimentaire
c'est 5 millions de morts par an
l'alcool c'est entre deux et trois
millions donc ça fait quand même des
tailles d'impact sont très significatifs
et donc on a beaucoup de décès par an
qui sont liés à des secteurs d'activité
industrielle
très bien peut-être
juste une question et puis je laisserais
bien sûr ensuite les collègues
s'exprimaient et vous interpeller
également si vous souhaitez un peu plus
développer avant cela le sujet nous
avons encore eu cette semaine des débats
sur le rôle des influenceurs
dans dans la publicité et finalement en
entendant votre propos on peut se poser
la question implacable de quel est le
bon équilibre convaincu que on ne peut
pas être dans l'interdiction totale
moins que on se réfère à la question que
je vous posais et donc on interdise tout
simplement certains produits le tabac
une forme d'alcool ou d'abus et on voit
bien en revanche qu'il y a un
développement très fort de la place ce
qu'on appelle les placements de produits
de plus en plus avec l'accélération et
la place des réseaux sociaux notamment
dans les populations les plus jeunes
avec évidemment des choses qui sont
impactantes on voit bien aussi la
difficulté pour le législateur de
trouver l'ajuste mesure chaque année
chaque projet de loi de finance la
sécurité sociale nous nous invite
parfois à essayer de limiter notamment
souvent sur la question des sodas par
exemple pour prendre un exemple et on
voit bien toute la difficulté trouver le
juste équilibre les alcools forts sur
les talents dans les outre-mer je me
souviens à chaque fois avec la question
des taxes enfin tous ces sujets qui
reviennent et pour lesquelles on a
parfois un peu de mal à mettre un
curseur entre bien sûr et je mange je
m'empresse d'ajouter la question
nécessaire de la prévention
dont on mesure la nécessité aujourd'hui
à fortiori avec le développement et
l'impact notamment des réseaux sociaux
d'une certaine forme de publicité et
puis
le positionnement un peu plus agressif
de certaines industries donc voilà quel
est selon vous pour rester quand même
avoir des raisons d'espérer qu'on puisse
demain peut-être arriver un meilleur
équilibre et notamment en matière de
politique publique les mesures qu'il
faudrait prendre à commencer par les
législateurs que nous sommes alors c'est
ce dont parle beaucoup le livre il y a
des risques qui ont été réprimés dans
l'histoire donc le tabac est un risque
qui est en voie de répression puisque le
tabagisme baisse dans le monde donc la
quantité totale de cigarettes fumée
augmente dans le monde par un effet
démographique mais le taux de tabagisme
donc le pourcentage d'une population qui
fume ça c'est quelque chose qui est en
baisse à l'échelle mondiale et en
particulier dans pas mal de pays surtout
dans les démocraties la pollution de
l'air est en baisse dans les pays riches
le plomb a baissé considérablement dans
le monde en général et surtout dans les
démocraties depuis les années 70 et les
États-Unis qui ont lancé ça avec la loi
sur l'air propre et donc il y avait deux
sources de plomb dans le monde qui était
la peinture et carburant il y a eu une
loi qui a dit bah c'est interdit et le
plomb a baissé la plombée des enfants
américains a baissé le quotient
intellectuel des enfants américains a
augmenté la violence a baissé puisque le
plan en violant
le l'alcool est en baisse dans certains
pays qui qui sont des pays riches et des
démocraties et qui ont pris des mesures
dont je vais parler juste après à chaque
fois que ces risques ont été réprimés
donc ces quatre gros risques le tabac
l'alcool dans certains pays le plomb et
la pollution de l'air dans les pays
riches à chaque fois que c'est risqué
ont été réprimés ça a été par une
intervention légale et une intervention
économique et donc une intervention
légale c'est soit par la loi directement
soit par la réglementation mais ça c'est
votre travail et à chaque fois avant
qu'on le fasse il y a plein de gens qui
ont dit ce que vous venez de dire juste
avant c'est-à-dire c'est difficile
l'équilibre et pas évident à trouver on
sait pas trop ce qu'on doit faire il
faut laisser des libertés et puis les
industries comme vous dites sont
agressifs c'est vous qui est utilisé ce
terme
et puis après quand c'était fait au bout
de quelques années tout le monde
trouvait ça super donc tous ces risques
ont été réprimés par un mélange de
législation et d'économique alors
l'économie ça veut dire qu'il faut
mettre un effet de marché pour que les
produits mauvais soient chers avec les
produits bon ça pas cher ça n'a pas été
fait pour les risques qui sont hors de
contrôle aujourd'hui donc le risque
alimentaire qui est un des pires risques
à la fois par la taille de son impact et
par sa croissance hors de contrôle c'est
un risque qui n'est pas régulé et pas
taxé et donc c'est un risque qu'on ne
maîtrise pas puisque l'obésité et les
maladies métaboliques sont en baisse
dans 0 pays dans le monde et c'est en
croissance en France
donc oui c'est la loi qui peut faire les
choses c'est pas les individus tout seul
dans un système qui est fait pour les
exposer à des risques
s'exprimer moi et sinon poursuivre
peut-être sur un sujet dont on sent que
la
place devient de plus en plus prégnante
dans l'alimentation c'est la question du
sucre qui revient avec un système dans
les débats beaucoup d'ouvrage on fait
référence au sucre à l'augmentation du
sucre dans l'ensemble finalement à des
produits beaucoup de produits consommés
et donc un rapport finalement qui est
parfois produit des effets assez
négatifs comme beaucoup l'ont souligné
et le deuxième deuxième question qui est
un peu sous-jacente à la première c'est
la corrélation et l'effet entre le prix
l'augmentation du prix et la
consommation est-ce que selon vous
au-delà de la réglementation c'est la
question du prix qui peut être un des
aspects limitatifs de la consommation de
certains des produits que vous avez
évoqués et qui de fassent consommer de
façon abusive sans nécessairement nocifs
pour pour la
alors le sucre effectivement est un des
composants négatifs du système
alimentaire mondial c'est pas le seul il
y a aussi le gras probablement un peu
moins finalement mais c'est mauvais
quand même le fait de façon générale de
trop transformer les aliments et le fait
que les aliments soient souvent
recouverts de produits chimiques qui
correspondent fréquemment à des
pesticides d'eau il y a beaucoup
d'ennemis dans le système alimentaire et
le sucre c'est un ennemi majeur
effectivement quand la population
mondiale a doublé la consommation de
sucre dans le monde a triplé donc est-ce
que on mange plus de sucre en moyenne la
réponse est oui
le sucre il est rajouté par les
industriels pour augmenter le caractère
attractif des produits et même pour
maintenant augmenter le caractère
addictif des produits puisque le sucré
addictif c'est quelque chose qui a été
montré à chaque fois que ça a été
recherché que ce soit chez l'homme chez
l'animal ou même à l'échelle
épidémiologique ou macroéconomique
et le sucre est très toxique
effectivement le sucre est en
particulier certains sucres qui sont
artificiellement rajoutés dans
l'alimentation comme le fructose sont
des produits qui sont très mauvais pour
la santé soit parce que ça rend obèse
soit parce que ça provoque des maladies
métaboliques sans forcément passer par
le stade de l'obésité
alors il y a du fructose dans les fruits
mais il est beaucoup moins concentré et
il est associé aux fibres ce qui fait
que le fructose des fruits dans
l'ensemble n'est pas mauvais pour la
santé alors que le fructose qui est
artificiellement rajouté l'ordre du
processus industriel est très mauvais
pour la santé
ça c'était pour votre première question
et donc la deuxième question sur le
l'aspect économique alors comme c'est
des produits qui aujourd'hui les
produits industriels surtout les
produits industriels ultra transformés
sont des produits qui en moyenne sont
moins chers que les produits frais donc
c'est pour ça que l'effet de marché est
complètement défavorable parce que c'est
plusieurs fois plus cher souvent de
manger frais par rapport à une
alimentation industrielle qui serait
trop transformée donc forcément ça crée
une désincitation à aller manger frais
sauf quand vous avez beaucoup de moyens
et d'ailleurs c'est un des déterminants
de ce qu'on appelle le gradient social
de santé pourquoi les gens qui ont moins
de capital social et économique sont
moins bonne santé c'est aussi parce
qu'ils peuvent manger ils ne peuvent pas
manger aussi bien que les gens qui ont
beaucoup de capital social et économique
il y a une addiction au sucre qui fait
que si on augmente un peu le prix de
certains produits sucrés les gens les
consomment quand même
on n'a pas vraiment d'expérimentation ou
les produits sucrés aurait été très
taxés comme on a pu essayer de le faire
pour le tabac et donc on ne sait pas ce
que ça donnerait mais on ne voit pas
enfin on pense que c'est une partie
quand même importante de la solution
de mettre une taxe très importante pour
rendre un peu inabordable ou en tout cas
dissuader les gens ou certaines
personnes d'acheter des produits qui
sont trop mauvais pour la santé je pense
en revanche qu'à titre personnel que si
ça n'est pas associé à une détaxes voire
à des prix négatifs pour qu'à la fin
l'équation économique soit neutre pour
les gens ce sera quelque chose qui ne
sera pas accepté si on veut mettre un
effet de marché dans l'alimentation moi
je pense que c'est une partie majeure de
la solution il faut qu'à la fin les gens
s'en sortent de façon identique par
rapport à avant l'intervention
économique et donc
il faut que ce soit que les gens
dépensent la même somme d'argent en tout
cas les 10 millions de Français qui sont
à 50 ou 100 euros près à la fin du mois
mais avec des produits frais à la place
des produits industriels
justement je veux bien volontir réagir
là-dessus parce qu'on a souvent cette
tendance alors qui est relativement vrai
alors peut-être permettez-moi cette
inflexion un peu plus quand on habite
dans un centre urbain où il est plus
difficile peut-être d'avoir accès à
certains produits frais que quand on a
la capacité à utiliser des circuits plus
courts
et donc se tourner vers une alimentation
peut-être
issue directement d'une agriculture
raisonnée de proximité
là il y a peut-être aussi un sujet et ça
m'amène tout de suite à la question de
de l'agriculture on a souvent
dire stigmatiser essayer
ou pointer du doigt notre agriculture et
les conséquences sur l'alimentation on
se retrouve aujourd'hui devant une
situation
où malheureusement
et singulièrement sur la question de
l'accès aux produits frais on a
peut-être une difficulté à se produire
et avoir accès à un certain nombre de
produits
issus de cette agriculture raisonnée de
l'agriculture biologique là encore avec
ce phénomène de proximité donc ne
faut-il pas aussi
revisiter notre notre modèle agricole on
va avoir des travaux sur la ferme France
il y a peut-être l'un un sujet important
c'est pour avoir votre votre vision et
parce qu'on est ici dans la délégation à
la prospective on se doit aussi un peu
d'éclairer l'avenir et par rapport à
cette question de l'agriculture du
rapport entre agriculture et
alimentation comment vous voyez
l'évolution comment faudrait-il
justement qu'on puisse nous réfléchir et
prendre des les dispositions qu'elle
serait selon vous les dispositions
nécessaires singulièrement sur cette
question de de l'agriculture alors je
suis pas un spécialiste de l'agriculture
mais j'ai essayé de répondre en partie
il y a des il y a plein de rapports qui
ont été faits par des organismes non
gouvernementaux sur la nécessité de
transition du modèle agricole je pense
qu'il y a pas toute là-dessus
et
là où ça rejoint votre question c'est
que ce que préconise ces rapports sur la
transition du modèle agricole
c'est quelque chose qui va également
dans le sens d'une transition
épidémiologique c'est-à-dire que la
transition du modèle agricole qui est
préconisé non pas pour des raisons
épidémiologiques mais souvent pour des
raisons environnementales
c'est une transition qui si elle se fait
ira dans le sens de ce qu'on vient de
discuter c'est-à-dire permettre que des
produits frais soient produits frais et
le moins chimique possible etc soit
économiquement abordable
et donc
c'est là où
il y a une bonne nouvelle dans tout ça
c'est que
la solution à tous les problèmes
environnementaux économique et
épidémiologique passe par le même type
de transition alors je pense par exemple
un rapport qui s'appelle after 2050
je crois le rapport d'une association
qui s'appelle Solagro dans le plan de
transformation de l'économie française
du chiffre project il y a un chapitre
sur agriculture donc il y a des gens qui
ont essayé de proposer des modèles de
transition et ces modèles de transition
je pense sont sérieux et moi je suis pas
un expert de ça mais je sais qu'ils vont
dans le même sens que ce qu'il faudrait
faire pour que l'alimentation soit
ensuite
moins dans un système qui a souvent
moins défaillant de toute façon quand il
y a une feuille de marché c'est le rôle
de législateur je crois de compenser ça
et donc je pense qu'effectivement il y a
un travail là-dessus mais qui qui ce
serait la même transition pour à la fois
l'environnement épidémiologique
[Musique]
qui est intervenu ici
elle est tout à fait dans votre sens il
disait que tout ce qui bouscule la
chaîne du vivant a des conséquences
sanitaires donc je voulais vous parler
un petit peu des zones
sachant qu'aujourd'hui on voit bien
qu'on est dans des crises récurrentes
gris pavières et sans parler d'autres
d'autres épidémies donc voilà au niveau
de au niveau de la chaîne alimentaire
quel est votre sentiment par rapport à
ça quel serait les mesures qui seraient
qui seraient qui seraient importante de
prendre pour pour limiter les effets qui
ont bien évidemment des impacts sur la
santé le
l'émergence des nouveaux pathogènes donc
c'est à dire des nouveaux microbes c'est
quelque chose qui est en croissance
linéaire depuis les années 60 donc
chaque décennie il y a plus de nouveaux
pathogènes émergents que la décennie
précédente depuis les années 60
c'est-à-dire depuis que ça a été mesuré
avant le mesurait pas vraiment au 21e
siècle il y a eu quatre pandémies en 11
ans ce qui n'a jamais existé de toute
l'histoire de l'humanité donc
effectivement l'émergence des nouveaux
pathogènes qui sont plus ou moins
problématiques le dernier ayant été très
problématique c'est quelque chose qui
est là encore causé par un modèle de la
société mondiale en l'occurrence c'est
lié beaucoup à la pression qui exercée
sur les espèces animales et à la
destruction de leurs habitats
parce que ce sont les nouveaux virus qui
sont la plupart des nouveaux pathogènes
émergents c'est rarement des bactéries
sont hébergés par les animaux et quand
une pression est exercée sur les animaux
les virus sautent sur une autre espèce
pour continuer à survivre en sachant
qu'un virus c'est même pas un être
vivant c'est une particule
et à chaque fois à chaque départ d'une
pandémie il y a un animal Zika a
commencé comme ça et bola a commencé
comme ça et
le covid-19 a commencé comme ça même si
on n'est pas sûr de l'animal donc là
encore c'est toujours le même
modèle de système industriel et aussi
beaucoup agricoles qui effectivement est
la cause de l'émergence des nouveaux
pathogènes et donc c'est pour ça que la
solution à tous nos problèmes passe par
le même type de transition ce qui veut
dire un changement de modèle énorme de
la société et c'est tellement énorme que
c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui ça n'a pas
été fait et qu'on en prend même pas le
chemin
merci Bernard fialer et puis ensuite
Cécile
poser des questions j'ai pas lu vos
livres pas encore mais peut-être et donc
je sais pas
moi je voulais savoir un titre plus
presque micro
si vous avez analysé on sait aussi par
exemple il y a certains quartiers dans
les métropoles où l'espérance de vie ou
les taux d'obésité de diabète sont plus
importants ça va qu'est-ce qui est le
plus important parce qu'on dit qu'il y a
des publicités qui sont qu'on trouve que
sur certains territoires des types de
consommation aussi enfin des
propositions la demande de consommation
aussi des problèmes de rythme de vie de
le marché bio qui est en milieu de
journée il est pas fait pour les gens
qui vont travailler pour aller faire les
achats il faut avoir une forme de de
disponibilité qu'on n'a pas donc je vais
savoir quels étaient vraiment les
critères qui vous paraissent les plus
importants pour ces inégalités
de santé en fonction comme ça de
territoire sur
sur une métropole ou sur d'autres pays
et la deuxième chose c'est savoir aussi
si l'Europe a à peu près les mêmes
critères aussi il y a des grosses
variations entre l'Europe du Sud
l'Europe du nord l'est et l'ouest
qu'elles sont vos analyses à chaque fois
il y a des disparités que ce soit entre
pays entre région d'un pays ou même
entre
sous-endroit dans le département c'est
très difficile de répondre à la première
question parce qu'il y a trop de
facteurs qui influencent la santé et
souvent les risques évoluent en cluster
au sein d'un groupe de population donnée
c'est à dire que les gens qui sont très
pauvres et qui habitent dans des
quartiers qui sont très dégradés bah ils
cumulent les risques donc ils ont ils
sont dans un environnement insalubre ils
ne font pas attention à leur santé parce
qu'ils ont d'autres préoccupations ils
n'ont pas les moyens de manger
correctement ils se trouvent quand même
un petit peu de moyens pour fumer et
ainsi de suite donc c'est c'est ils
évoluent dans un feedback positif mais
dans le sens négatif du terme c'est à
dire que les les risques provoquent les
risques et c'est impossible de savoir si
c'est plutôt la publicité plutôt la
pauvreté plutôt la proximité avec un
supermarché où il n'y a pas de produits
frais mais tous ces facteurs jouent mais
on ne sait pas dans quelle proportion
joue chacun de ces facteurs
ensuite entre les pays d'Europe bien sûr
il y a des différences qui sont très
importantes en termes de fréquence de
maladies métaboliques et d'obésité donc
l'Angleterre c'est un des pays où il y
en a le plus
l'Italie c'est un des pays en Allemagne
la France est un petit peu entre les
deux mais même en France il y a des
différences qui sont très importantes
dans le Nord et dans l'Est il y a plus
de maladies métaboliques et d'obésité
que dans sur la côte atlantique par
exemple
donc oui il y a des disparités qui sont
liées à tous ces facteurs dont on vient
de parler qui s'entremêlent les uns les
autres et qu'il est très difficile de
démêler y compris sur le plan
statistique
merci
sans vouloir poser une question qui qui
inviterait ou fatalisme mais bon
vous expliquer les différentes
évolutions la nécessité aujourd'hui
compris de changer de modèle pour
répondre
aux enjeux
présentés
est-ce qu'il n'y a pas là en tout cas on
l'entend parfois et n'étant pas du tout
spécialiste du sujet aussi une
adaptabilité de l'espèce humaine
finalement qui fait que aujourd'hui les
mots décrits et qu'on chercherait à
éviter demain
deviendrait
d'autres mots donc même en changeant
radicalement de de système de production
dans tous les secteurs en repensant les
alimentations et donc compris avec
l'intervention du législateur est-ce
qu'il n'y aurait pas demain
inévitablement lié finalement à l'espèce
humaine et son lien avec la nature
d'autres épidémies qui pourraient se
développer et qui font finalement
dans ce que vous invitez à réfléchir ce
n'est pas le problème de toute société
d'avoir le souci permanent de la santé
de ces individus
plutôt que de laisser reposer je n'ai
pas ce que vous avez dit qu'il y aurait
un modèle de développement qui pourrait
préserver a priori de toute épidémie et
maladies les individus qui la composent
ça c'est la première question et la
deuxième question
vous avez insisté et c'est une réalité
sur les conséquences d'une société
post-révolution industrielle qui
aujourd'hui qui certainement peut-être à
bout de souffle qui est devenu même
aujourd'hui une société de consommation
cependant si on regarde à l'échelle de
l'humanité
paradoxalement il y a certainement plus
de crises sanitaire et plus de
d'épidémies de pandémie mais on vit
aussi globalement à l'échelle de
[Musique]
pas par une intention supérieure mais
juste parce que la société mondiale est
mal faite et on pourrait produire moins
de risques ce qui serait à la fois
meilleur pour l'environnement pour la
santé et pour le bien-être
ensuite pour votre deuxième question on
vit moins longtemps en France qui a
quelques années les États-Unis ont
baissé leur espérance de vie à partir de
2014 et 21 pic en 2014 et à partir 2015
ça a commencé à baisser
l'Angleterre a aussi une stagnation ou
une baisse de l'espérance de vie dans
certains segments de population
la mortalité infantile augmente en
France depuis 2012 Quand la mortalité
infantile augmente ça ne veut pas dire
que les bébés sont intrinsèquement en
mauvaise santé ça veut pas dire que le
système de soins s'en occupe pas c'est à
dire que les mamans sont en mauvaise
santé les mamans en général c'est des
femmes qui ont entre 25 et 40 ans donc
la santé régresse sur beaucoup
d'indicateurs y compris dans les pays
riches donc oui on vit plus longtemps
aujourd'hui qui a 300 ans et même qui a
100 ans mais la santé se dégrade
beaucoup par rapport à il y a 20 ou 30
ans
merci Stéphane sotarel oui merci j'avais
une question autour de l'équilibre
liberté individuelle et
cadre collectif contraignant ou
législatif et illustré sur la question
de l'alimentation
parce qu'effectivement vous faites la
remarque qu'aujourd'hui il y a un sujet
à la fois de qualité d'alimentation et
de coude d'alimentation et je trouve que
c'est une approche un petit peu
réductrice parce que si on regarde le
budget des ménages la part de
l'alimentation et doit être aujourd'hui
à peu près la moitié de ce qu'elle était
il y a 30 ou 35 ans je crois
qu'aujourd'hui d'une ménage accorde à
peu près 12 et demi ou 13% à
l'alimentation là où c'était 26 ou 27%
dans les années 70 et donc je trouve que
d'avoir une approche uniquement par une
contrainte ou par un encadrement sur
l'alimentation alors qu'il y a aussi des
choix individuels dans les budgets qui
font que on préfère aujourd'hui avoir
trois téléphones et deux abonnements à
Netflix que de manger correctement ça
pose d'autres questions voilà c'était ça
c'était une remarque
par rapport à ce que vous avez indiqué
sur strictement l'alimentation et par
ailleurs
j'entendais là dans le débat actuel sur
l'aspect de de l'inflation dans
l'alimentation une information qui me
semblait assez contraire à celle que
vous nous donnez à savoir que les
produits industriels les plats préparés
etc sont aujourd'hui globalement plus
cher que si j'achète des des aliments de
base et que je me remets à cuisiner et
donc il y a à la fois un aspect sans
doute de qualité et donc santé et en
même temps budget donc voilà je voulais
revenir sur ce point de l'alimentation
qui me semble pour être abordé de
manière un peu plus un peu plus large un
peu plus globale avec peut-être d'autres
des décisions à prendre aussi qui
peuvent rentrer dans le domaine
législatif mais qui renvoie aussi de la
responsabilité individuelle façon un peu
plus large alors pour la première
question vous avez commencé votre
question par liberté et aujourd'hui il y
a plein de gens qui sont pas libres
d'acheter ce qu'ils veulent à manger
parce qu'ils n'ont pas l'argent parce
que les aliments trop transformés sont
ubiquitaires et quand vous avez quelque
chose qui est omniprésent autour de vous
vous êtes porté pour aller acheter ça
ensuite parce qu'il y a de l'addiction
la dépendance on m'a appris que c'était
l'inverse de la liberté et ainsi de
suite donc aujourd'hui de toute façon il
n'y a pas une liberté qui est bonne pour
plein de gens par rapport à ce avec quoi
ils peuvent se nourrir
[Musique]
une liste qui en appel à la
responsabilité des gens en leur disant
et ben les gens sont responsables on ne
touche pas à l'offre de risque on laisse
les industriels faire ce qu'ils veulent
en termes de publicité en termes de prix
en termes de place qui prennent dans les
rayons des supermarchés ou ailleurs et
on dit aux gens évitez si éviter ça n'en
faites pas trop ne le faites pas on
laisse faire c'est moins cher c'est
valorisé y compris peut-être par les
influenceurs je ne sais pas et mais on
vous dit il faut pas le faire et ça
qu'on le juge moralement ou pas je
voulais pas juger moralement mais quand
le juge moralement ou pas ça ne marche
pas sinon on n'en serait pas là on
aurait pas une croissance de l'obésité
dans quasiment 100% des pays du monde et
donc les risques qui ont réussi à être
un peu mieux maîtrisé que celui là c'est
quand on a agi sur l'offre puisque
l'offre influence trop la demande et
quand on a dit ben on n'a pas le droit
de fumer dans certains endroits on n'a
pas le droit de faire de la publicité
pour les cigarettes on n'a pas le droit
de fumer à partir de tel âge on n'a pas
le droit de vendre des cigarettes à tel
endroit et toutes ces choses là qui
effectivement ont une relation
compliquée avec la liberté c'est ce qui
a marché pour le tabac et aujourd'hui je
crois que franchement personne ne s'en
plaint ça n'a pas été fait pour
l'alimentation on a le droit de vendre
des aliments très mauvais pour la santé
en face des écoles
on a le droit de faire la publicité pour
ça on a le droit de ne pas réguler la
place que ça prend dans les supermarchés
j'avais deux autres deux autres
questions si
synthétise un petit peu l'ensemble du de
votre propos on peut
supposer qu'il y a aujourd'hui une
dégradation
générale de l'état de santé de l'espèce
humaine faut-il en conclure qu'il y a
aussi un risque sur le sur le patrimoine
génétique à terme ça c'est la première
question on a beaucoup parlé de
d'alimentation de tabac d'alcool
beaucoup de spécialistes de la santé on
pointe du doigt notamment ressortir de
la crise sanitaire la question de la
santé mentale
sur ce point là est-ce que quel est
votre quel est votre avis est-ce qu'il y
a une augmentation du phénomène
post covid mais est-ce qu'on observait
déjà avant convaincu que c'est un sujet
une part de la santé qui est peut-être
parfois un peu oublié et un impact assez
fort sur la plupart de sur la première
certaine sur la première question assez
rapidement non pas de d'impact
détectable ni même qu'on pourrait
soupçonner sur le patrimoine génétique
on ne sait pas où va aller la démocratie
mondiale les démographes font leur
projection mais ils ne tiennent pas
compte justement de la place prise par
les maladies ni de l'évolution des
systèmes de soins qui sont pas toujours
apte à faire face même sur la génétique
je vois pas trop de relation sur la
santé mentale le fardeau de la santé
mentale c'est le premier faire deux
épidémiologique au monde depuis 30 ans
c'est quelque chose qui est stable donc
si vous êtes visionnez les années de vie
perdue et les années de vie malade c'est
la santé mentale qui prend le plus de
place les il y a une différence dans le
fardeau épidémiologique mondial entre
ceux dont les gens meurent et ceux dont
les gens souffrent donc ce dont les gens
meurent c'est toujours pareil c'est en
numéro 1 cardiovasculaire en numéro 2
cancer et puis après les maladies
respiratoires et le diabète par contre
ceux dans les gens souffrent c'est les
maladies articulaires les sentimentale
les addictions et les pertes
sensorielles c'est à dire audition et
vision et donc la santé mentale c'est un
fardeau énorme qui ne tue pas beaucoup
mais qui fait énormément souffrir c'est
complètement stable depuis 30 ans
pendant le covid ça a eu tendance à
s'accentuer c'est difficile à mesurer
mais aujourd'hui est-ce qu'il y a un
problème de santé mondiale dans le monde
oui bien sûr est-ce que il est traité
correctement non est-ce que il y a un
problème sentimental en France oui
est-ce qu'il a tendance à s'accentuer
sous l'effet des nouveaux risques qui
sont donc les aliments parfois trop
transformés ou les réseaux sociaux
numériques oui
très bien
est-ce que les collègues souhaitent
peut-être juste sur cette
dernière point pour le prolonger la
question ou l'orienter plus
spécifiquement sur la jeunesse les ados
ou une tranche un peu plus large je ne
sais pas où est-ce qu'on peut fixer les
bornes mais à la fois avec
la crise sanitaire et les impacts que ça
peut avoir plus particulièrement sur
cette sur ce public là avec
certaines addictions alimentaires plus
d'autres réseaux sociaux etc etc et donc
le risque amplifié que ça représente
pour notre société et si on est sur la
prospective de ce que ça va produire
déclencher dans un nez qui viennent
voilà donc peut-être une question plus
orientée sur ce public là qui me semble
aujourd'hui peu prise en compte d'une
manière globale
oui bien sûr c'est un public qui est
très exposé et qui est donc il est
exposé ça veut dire il est juste
exposition quantitative et ensuite qui
est vulnérable à ça parce que c'est plus
facile pour nous de nous défendre contre
des tentations que des gens qui ont
entre 15 et 30 ans et il est exposé donc
à ses risques dont on vient de parler et
pour parler donc le livre ne parle pas
des réseaux sociaux numériques pas du
tout parce qu'il y a pas il y a beaucoup
de données mais il y en a beaucoup moins
que dans les autres risques traités donc
j'ai fait exprès de pas en parler parce
qu'il y a moins de recul mais il y a
déjà suffisamment de données pour
suggérer que c'est très mauvais parce
que c'est addictif c'est moins pour la
santé mentale ça augmente le risque
d'obésité
et ainsi de suite et là encore c'est une
offre qui n'est pas régulée qui n'est
pas taxée
alors que vous savez parce que je pense
où vous l'avez vu il y a eu une lanceuse
d'alerte qui est une ex Instagram qui a
je crois qu'elle a été auditionnée par
le Parlement américain pour dire que
la stratégie d'Instagram sur les ados
avait fait l'objet d'un plan spécifique
que c'était le même type d'approche qui
avait fait l'industrie du tabac et donc
ça ça
amener un certain degré de
conscientisation aux États-Unis sur le
problème pour autant c'est voilà c'est
pas régulé c'est pas taxé oui c'est un
très gros problème surtout pour les
jeunes
moi j'aurais voulu des précisions vous
avez dit que l'espérance de vie
commençait on était auparavant on
gagnait un an tous les quatre ans
c'était même davantage c'est tous les
ans même pour les personnes handicapées
c'était et là et puis l'augmentation
aussi d'ailleurs en bonne santé avec
quand même augmenté aussi pendant
quelques mois moins moins mais aussi un
peu on en est où et la deuxième chose
c'est
le facteur donc de la sédentarité vous
allez dire quand on parle de l'obésité
ça intervient
aussi
vous avez des des analyses sur ce qui a
pu être fait par exemple pour que les
gens puissent davantage bouger leur il y
a les fesses secondaires des réseaux
sociaux quand les gens passent leur
temps devant un écran plutôt qu'à bouger
c'est
quelque chose d'important mais vous avez
des
sur le premier qui est l'espérance de
vie
l'espérance de vie donc
l'Insee a un rapport en janvier sur
l'espérance de vie française en 2019 qui
a arrêté 2022 pardon qui est arrêté à
novembre 2022 donc il manque un mois et
qui montre que l'espérance de vie en
France a soit stagné soit baissé selon
la catégorie de population étudiée par
rapport à 2019 qui est justement la
dernière année de référence puisque
c'est l'année la dernière année sans
pandémie
et donc il y a d'autres pays on monte ça
aux États-Unis c'est encore pire en
Angleterre c'est pas c'est moins bien
aussi
le après l'espérance de vie c'est une
moyenne nationale et donc tout à l'heure
je disais par exemple que l'espérance de
vie BC aux États-Unis depuis 2015
l'espérance de vie continue d'augmenter
à New York elle continue d'augmenter en
Californie par contre entre les deux
côtes à part le Texas ou il s'en sortent
c'est pas bon du tout ça continue de
plonger donc si vous regardez les
moyennes nationales si vous ne
désagrégez pas les données vous ne
pouvez pas voir là où ce passe les
problèmes
peut-être que dans certains quartiers de
Paris certains arrondissements de Paris
l'espérance de vie continue d'augmenter
je pense que c'est le cas je pense en
revanche que il y a des régions ou des
villes où elle baisse mais on ne mesure
pas forcément directement
alors la sédentarité bah oui c'est un
fait qui est avéré on bouge moins
qu'avant par rapport à il y a 20 30 40
50 ans moi j'ai pas la solution à ça il
y a une multitude de facteurs qui jouent
comme un modèle de société le manque de
temps les écrans en font partie
la conception des villes en fait partie
mais la sédentarité est un des trois
facteurs qui jouent un rôle dans la
pandémie d'obésité mondiale les deux
autres facteurs étant la quantité
d'alimentation et la qualité de
l'alimentation
en prolongement de ce que vient de dire
Bernard moi je crois qu'il y a un sujet
qui est quand même important notamment
en matière de politique publique on sait
par exemple s'agissant de l'alimentation
que beaucoup d'enfants
ont essentiellement quand ils sont
notamment de pensionnaires qui fréquente
les cantines des établissements
scolaires parfois trouve là notamment
pour les familles les moins aisées moins
aisés pardon
le seul repas équilibré en tout cas
c'est analysé comme tel dans plusieurs
dans plusieurs études et c'est souvent
ce que font remonter aussi à beaucoup de
collectivités beaucoup de municipalités
donc on voit le rôle important
du repas qui est partagé de l'approche
et je parlais tout à l'heure de la
prévention qui peut être fait aussi
à l'école au niveau de l'enseignement
peut-être également faut-il accentuer
les les politiques en tout cas c'est ce
que c'est plusieurs de nos collègues ont
rappelé dans des rapports notamment sur
le groupe d'études sur le sport la place
du sport à l'école est-ce que c'est pas
culturellement aussi quelque chose sur
lequel il faut faire porter un effort
particulier parce que le problème la
problématique de la sédentarité que vous
évoquez qui évoquez Bernard c'est un des
sujets quand même qui
viennent perturber
cette problématique et cet équilibre
entre l'alimentation et la nécessité
effectivement de bouger si on veut venir
contrarier notamment un facteur
d'obésité si sûrement j'avoue que je ne
suis pas un spécialiste de ça et j'ai
pas d'idées lumineuse là-dessus
effectivement j'ai entendu que
l'alimentation à l'école c'était quelque
chose qui était assez contrôlé pour que
ce soit dans les bons standards et donc
effectivement tant mieux
idem pour le sport
j'ai pas de problème avec ça mais
honnêtement j'ai pas je crois que j'ai
pas de commentaire particulier à faire
là-dessus sauf si j'ai mal compris votre
question
la contrainte et de réglementation de
législation est-ce qu'il n'y a pas aussi
à inciter à inviter peut-être si si bien
sûr il y a des encouragements qui sont
possibles que ce soit sur le plan
économique ou sur le plan de non
économique mais tout à l'heure quand on
parle des économie j'ai parlé
d'encouragement par des datations ou
même par des subventions ou des prix
négatifs si on vous donne un euro pour
sortir du supermarché avec un fruit je
pense que plein de gens le feront et
après soit il le jette ça fait du
compost soit il le mange et il commence
un petit peu à prendre du plaisir à
manger autre chose que des produits
industriels et donc ça coûte de l'argent
mais ça coûte de l'argent aussi de
rembourser des médicaments
antidiabétiques ou des chirurgies contre
l'obésité
merci beaucoup pour l'invitation
il y a un truc majeur dont on n'a pas
parlé je suis étonné c'est le
nutri-score
voilà non mais parce que à chaque fois
on pose la question dessus donc si vous
voulez j'en parle donc le nutri-score
c'est un score qui a été développé par
une équipe française pour classer
l'alimentation de très bons à très
mauvais selon cinq stades et c'est basé
sur les calories ils sont en train de le
faire évoluer pour incorporer aussi des
données de transformation donc pour que
le nutriscor reflète de façon plus large
le caractère bon ou mauvais de
l'alimentation ça marche dans le sens où
on sait que ça influence le comportement
d'achat des gens et ça marche avec un
deuxième effet et c'est là où ça répond
un peu à la question qu'on avait c'est
que du coup les industriels sans le dire
ont changé des centaines et peut-être
même des milliers de recettes pour que
leurs produits se transfère vers des
catégories plus favorables les plus
attractives donc ça c'est un truc qui
marche d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que les
industriels n'en voulaient pas quand les
industriels ne veulent pas de changement
c'est que ils savent que ça va marcher
c'est il n'empêche que ça n'est pas
obligatoire donc ça n'est même pas de la
régulation et ça reporte toujours sur
les individus la responsabilité de se
débrouiller
sans les aider sur le plan économique
donc ils savent ce qui est bon mauvais
mais si c'est deux fois plus cher ce qui
est dans le vert par rapport à ce qui
est dans le rouge ça ne résout pas tout
leur problème alors c'est 60%
aujourd'hui des produits qui sont
nutrisccorés il y a des discussions à
l'échelle de l'Europe pour que ça
devienne plus ou moins obligatoire moi
je pense que le coup est parti et que ça
va continuer de se développer ça montre
à peut être pas à 100% mais je pense que
ça va continuer avec le cas
et donc c'est une preuve que on peut
éclairer un peu les gens là-dedans
néanmoins c'est pas obligatoire et ça ne
tient pas compte des autres choses dont
on a parlé pour ce qui est de la
régulation par exemple on pourrait très
bien imaginer que les produits qui sont
malnutriscorés soit justement
interdit de publicité ou alors que le
packaging ne puisse pas être sexy ou
alors que on n'est pas le droit de les
vendre dans certains endroits comme les
enceintes sportives ou à proximité des
écoles c'est vrai que c'est une atteinte
certaine liberté mais quand on est
malade on n'est pas très libre ça je
peux vous le dire donc c'est une liberté
contre une autre et tout ça c'est des
pistes qui me paraissent pas très
violentes et qui pourtant aurait un
effet d'échelle massif parce que tout le
monde mange
si je peux poser une ultime question
vous avez évoqué bien évidemment la
recrudescence très forte de l'obésité
des problèmes cardio-vasculaires
s'agissant des cancers est-ce que vous
voyez apparaître alors là c'est certain
d'abord l'obésité est associée à un
suriste de 13 cancer donc l'obésité en
soi augmente le risque de plein de
cancer ensuite il y a des cancers qui
sont en baisse le cancer de l'estomac
est en baisse par exemple
et il y a des cancers qui sont en hausse
le cancer du testicule est en hausse
probablement à cause des perturbateurs
endocriniens le cancer colorectal est en
hausse et je pense que vous en avez tous
entendu parler parce que c'est beaucoup
lié notamment à l'alimentation ultra
transformée et au nitrite et je sais que
il y a un de vos collègues
parlementaires qui a essayé de faire
passer une législation sur une nitrite
et que ça a été refusé il y a même pas
deux trois semaines et donc le cancer
colorectal est en hausse moi je suis
gastro-entérologue donc on voit tous des
cancers colorectaux en plus c'est des
gens beaucoup plus jeunes qu'avant c'est
à dire entre 35 et 50 ans alors que la
moyenne d'âge c'était 63 ans et qu'on
envoyait quasiment pas avant 50 ans
aujourd'hui on envoie entre 35 et 50 et
en plus ils sont pas dépistés ces gens
là parce qu'ils sont pas dans le cadre
du dépistage de populationnel
ils sont pas dépistés donc ils arrivent
avec un diagnostic plus ou moins tardif
le cancer du pancréas est en hausse le
cancer du pancréas est en haut c'est le
cancer du pancréas deviendra bientôt aux
États-Unis mais dans plein de pays
riches comparables la deuxième cause de
mortalité par cancer donc oui bien sûr
il y a des cancers qui sont en hausse
c'est pas pour des raisons génétiques
parce que l'espèce génétique n'a pas
enfin
notre génome n'a pas muté en si peu de
temps et donc c'est pour des raisons qui
sont alimentaires et environnementales
donc ça fait partie c'est encore une
couche de phare de supplémentaire pour
une industrie qui n'évolue pas dans ces
pratiques
le cancer de l'estomac est en baisse
parce qu'on a notamment parce que il y a
il était très lié à une bactérie qui
s'appelle Helicobacter pylori qui a été
diagnostique enfin découverte dans les
années 80 par quelqu'un qui a eu le prix
Nobel de médecine ensuite et que cette
bactérie maintenant est presque
systématiquement éliminée quand on la
diagnostique avec un traitement
antibiotique voilà donc c'est une des
raisons principales pour lesquelles le
cancer de l'estomac est en baisse on
envoie pas beaucoup en revanche pour les
autres cancers il y en a qui sont en
rose
très bien écoutez il nous reste encore
une fois merci pour
cette excellent merci
nous revenons à ces largement
merci pour l'invitation